Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader  Ginsburg says she isn't going anywhere  anytime soon  the Justice reportedly said yesterday  she hopes to stay on the bench for at  least another five years Ginsburg made  the comments after a play about the late  Justice Antonin Scalia  she told journalists she's 85 and that  Justice John Paul Stevens was 90 when he  retired so she thinks she has at least  that long Ginsburg has was appointed in  the Supreme Court back in 1993 you know  no matter what your views on her rulings  are you gotta admit they call her the  notorious RBG for a reason he sets the  standards and working out being smart  you know well into your late 80s it's  very lot of eyes on Ruth Bader  Ginsburg's workout regime because well  we'll see a lot hangs in the balance